bereits vor achtung 3,42 milliarden
jahren gab es leben auf der erde
einzeller die an warmen quellen unter
dem meeresboden existierten fachleute
haben jetzt die frühesten belege für
mikroben die methan verstoffwechseln
überhaupt gefunden und diese
erkenntnisse können uns auch bei unserer
suche nach leben auf fremden welten
hilfreich sein klicks um seinen flug
james dreimal pro woche spannende
science videos abonniert den kanal und
aktiviert die glocken nur so verpasst
ihr nichts zu sehen
herzlich willkommen es handelt sich wohl
um einige der frühesten bekannten
organismen überhaupt auf der erde
einzeller die methan produzierten und
das bereits verachtung 3,42 milliarden
jahren ein italienisches forschungsteam
hat hinweise auf diese mikroorganismen
in einem sedimentgestein aufgespürt das
aus dem button greenstone belt im
nordosten von afrika stammt hier fanden
sich zwei fadenförmige strukturen von
mikro fossilien deren chemische
zusammensetzung äußerst spannende
hinweise bietet in einer aktuellen
studie beschreiben die italienischen
fachleute jetzt wie der damalige
lebensraum dieser mikroorganismen
ausgesehen haben muss diese neuen
erkenntnisse sind nicht nur spannend
weil sie verdeutlichen wann und unter
welchen umständen das auf der frühen
erde bereits leben gehabt auch für
unsere intensive suche nach
außerirdischem leben könnten diese
erkenntnisse äußerst hilfreich sein denn
solche spuren von früheren leben auf der
erde lassen rückschlüsse darauf zu
welche umgebung auch auf anderen
planeten die chance für die entstehung
von leben bieten alle spannenden infos
zu diesem sensationsfund und was der
auch für unsere suche nach potenziellen
leben auf fremden planeten und monden
bedeutet das gibt es jetzt jeweilig zum
salz im future mal wieder wurden die
fachleute im button grünsteingürtel
fündig die ältesten spuren des lebens
verstecken sich wohl genau hier es
handelt sich um ein gebirge das an der
grenze zwischen südafrika und dem
königreich es war teenie verläuft seine
gesteine gehören zu den ältesten der
erdoberfläche und mit recht wird dieser
grünsteingürtel oft auch als genesis of
life bezeichnet also übersetzt so viel
wie entstehung des lebens
das material ist achtung bis zu 3,6
milliarden jahre alt entstanden ist es
damit also als die erde mit einer
milliarde jahren noch sehr jung war
älteres gestein hatten andere
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
in der vergangenheit bislang nur in
grönland aufgespürt als das italienische
forschungsteam das sedimentgestein
genauer ins visier nahm stießen die
fachleute auf zwei fadenförmige
strukturen von mikro fossilien bei der
chemischen analyse wurde schnell klar
dass es sich um fossilien frühere
einzeller handeln muss doch wie können
sich die vorstellen dabei so sicher sein
können sie sich nicht auch um auffällige
strukturen im gestein handeln die
fachleute stützen sich bei ihrer annahme
vor allem auf die kohlenstoff reiche
hülle die die fäden und gibt diese
erinnert tatsächlich eine zellmembran
des weiteren konnte das forschungsteam
im inneren verschiedene elemente
aufspüren bei der analyse konnten unter
anderem nickel verbindungen nachgewiesen
werden dieses metall kam auf der jungen
erde wohl sehr häufig vor zu dem weg das
gleich assoziationen an moderne archen
die methan verstoffwechseln aber auch
andere wichtige bausteine von leben wie
beispielsweise kohlenstoff wasserstoff
sauerstoff und stickstoff konnten in den
fossilien gefunden werden ein wirklich
spektakulärer fund den fossilien von
aachen sind bislang sehr selten wie das
forschungsteam schreibt in der aktuellen
studie gehen die fachleute davon aus
dass diese versteinerten einzeller vor
etwa 3,42 milliarden jahren auf der
frühen erde gelebt haben ähnliche funde
von all jenen die einen deutlich methan
produzieren wurden auf ein alter von
etwa einer halben milliarde da tieren
also deutlich jünger als die aktuelle
funde dazu heißt es vom forschungsteam
obwohl wir wissen dass er versteinert
werden können fehlt es uns bislang an
direkten beispiel unsere ergebnisse
erlauben es uns nun die archea fossilen
zum ersten mal in die zeit auszudehnen
in der das erste leben auf der erde
entstand als archea werden in der
fachwelt übrigens einzellige organismen
bezeichnet die in sich geschlossenen
dna-moleküle aufweisen diese sind in
ihrem zellplasma zu finden quasi als
äquivalent zum zellkern der in gold
chaotischen zellen zu finden ist ebenso
wie eine zellmembran bei den
aufgespürten organismen handelt es sich
übrigens nicht um die ältesten bekannten
organismen vor drei jahren hatte ein
forschungsteam knapp 3,5 milliarden
jahre alte fossilien in australien
aufgespürt spuren von leben in kanada
und grönland die möglicherweise bereits
mehr als 3,7 milliarden jahre alt sind
wurden ebenfalls in anderen studien
beschrieben genauso wie mehr als 395
milliarden jahre alte über plätze von
organismen in kanada die ein japanisches
forschungsteam gefunden haben will bei
aller euphorie muss hier beachtet werden
dass solche alten funde nicht immer
zweifelsfrei organismen zuzuordnen sind
in diesem fall aber schon spannend für
die fachleute sind hier unter anderem
auch die stoffwechselwege mit denen die
mikroben einfachen kohlenwasserstoff
umsetzten diese wege scheinen eltern
zusammen möglicherweise gab es diese
sogar schon in der anfangszeit des
lebens auch zu den fragen wie und wo
diese mikroben gelebt haben müssen
stellen die fachleute einige spannende
vermutungen auf ihr lebensraum waren
wohl heiße quellen unter dem meeresboden
dazu schreibt das forschungsteam die
außergewöhnlich gut erhaltenen
versteinerten mikroben haben anscheinend
an den wänden von spalten gelebt die das
warme wasser hydrothermale systeme
einige meter unter dem meeresboden
geschaffen hat das heiße wasser aus den
spalten hat sich demnach mit dem
kühleren mehr wasser vermischt und genau
das bot wohl ziemlich gute bedingungen
damit sich leben entwickeln konnte dazu
sagt die verantwortliche
wissenschaftlerin barbara kavala sie wir
haben außergewöhnlich gut erhaltene
beweise für versteinerte mikroben
gefunden diese lebten wohl entlang der
wände von hohlräumen die durch warmes
wasser aus hydrothermalen system einige
meter unter dem meeresboden entstanden
waren diese lebensräume unter dem
untergrund wurden durch vulkanische
aktivität erhitzt und beherbergten
wahrscheinlich einige der frühesten
mikrobiellen ökosysteme der erbe das was
wir gefunden haben ist das älteste
beispiel das bislang aufgespürt werden
konnte heißt also der aktuelle fund ist
demnach der älteste beleg für ein
solches ökosystem und verdeutlicht noch
einmal wie wichtig heiße quellen für
früheres leben auf der erde war die nun
aufgespürten mikroorganismen waren der
aktuellen studie zufolge optimal auf die
besonderen bedingungen ihrer umwelt
angepasst möglicherweise handelt es sich
bei den hydrothermalquellen um den
ersten lebensraum an denen sich gepasst
wurde vorstellbar ist aber auch dass das
sehen wir sogar entstanden ist ein
münchner forschungsteam hatte erst vor
einiger zeit darauf hingewiesen dass
geothermale quellen die vulkanische
basiere entscheidend für die entstehung
von leben auf der erde gewesen sein
könnten die fachleute hatten in einem
experiment gezeigt dass für die synthese
der direkten vorstufen für purine und
pyramiden nicht wirklich komplizierte
bedingungen gegeben sein müssen also der
substanzen die ein grundlegender
bestandteil der dna unseres erbgutes
sind demnach müssten einfachste
chemische zutaten und
reaktionsbedingungen wie sie auf der
erde vor millionen von jahren alt war
auf geothermalen feldern mit
vulkanischer aktivität im untergrund
oder aber auch den flachen teilchen zu
finden gewesen sein dürften dafür
ausgereicht haben im experiment hatten
dem münchner fachleute die bildung der
ur erde simuliert und herausgekommen
waren die sogenannten
nukleotide dabei handelt es sich eben um
die direkten vorstufen der purine und
pury medine als zutaten für ihren mann
todd also eintopf nutzte das münchner
forschungsteam substanzen wie
ameisensäure harnstoff und ammoniak also
sehr einfache substanzen in zug am salz
und metalle die in der erdkruste
vorkommen unter anderem die tritte und
karbonate sowie eisen und zink die
chemischen kettenreaktionen wurden
angetrieben durch nass trocken zyklen
auf der erde könnten diese
beispielsweise durch regen und
dürreperioden entstanden sein oder aber
durch hydrothermale quellen die
fachleute selbst waren überrascht wie
einfach die reaktions bedingungen
eigentlich waren und doch für die
synthese solch komplexer moleküle
sorgten ein starkes indiz dafür dass
sich diese reaktions schritte
tatsächlich auf der frühen erde
abgespielt haben könnten diese
erkenntnis stärkt die theorie dass das
leben gar nicht im meer entstanden ist
die wiege des lebens liegt demnach fiel
er in flachen tümpeln und heißen quellen
die benötigten bedingungen für diese
reaktionen könnten aber auch in
geothermalen quellen wie vulkanischen
basieren geherrscht haben doch nicht nur
auf unserem heimatplaneten sondern auch
auf fremden planeten und monden draußen
im weltall könnte die chance demnach
groß sein dass sich leben entwickelt auf
dem saturnmond enceladus werden ja genau
solche heißen quellen vermutet die nun
aufgespürt micro fossilien erweitern
also unser verständnis und die grenzen
dafür welche umgebung auf der frühen
erde und auf anderen planeten oder monde
potenziell bewohnbar sind dazu heißt es
von den wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftlern aus italien da wir
beispielsweise auf dem mars ähnlicher
umgebung finden hat die studie auch
auswirkungen auf die astrobiologie und
die chance leben auch außerhalb der erde
zu finden spannend spannend spannend
leben in der todeszone außerirdisches
leben unter eis der antarktis entdeckt
auch heute wird auf der erde leben unter
absolut extremen bedingungen entdeckt
anklicken anschauen und abonnieren das
geht auch hier also hier draufklicken
oder unter jedem video mit dem abo
button kostet nichts und macht schlauch
bis dann bleibt dran